[Musique]
un grand honneur pour moi de vous dire
que vous êtes unis par c'est l'autre
grande loi phare du quinquena de
François Hollande après le mariage pour
tous le mariage des régions lancé en
janvier 2014 les collectivités seront
également incité et invité à se
rapprocher région d'abord dont le nombre
peut aussi
évoluer voici la nouvelle carte de
France il n a plus 22 mais 13 grandes
régions derrière ce découpage des
tractations des blocages mais aussi
quelques mariages d'amour l'objectif
c'est que on soit prêt et donc on a une
année pour préparer toucher au
territoire c'est aussi ouvrir la boîte
de Pandore Françis Hollande veut prendre
ce risque faut bien que le peup se bouge
sinon les politiciens il font ce qu'ils
veulent on perd beaucoup d'argent on
perd beaucoup d'efficacité avec cette
solution c'est une mauvaise idée
entre les Alsaciens irréductible Gaulois
qui veulent faire cavalier seul et les
partisans d'une vaste Bretagne réunifiée
le débat tourne parfois au
casse-tête en quelques mois pas moins de
quatre versions de la carte vont être
mis sur la table aucune carte ne fera
jamais l'unanimité le consensus total il
n'existe pas nous allons vous raconter
le parcours chaotique de la réforme
territoriale jusqu'à son adoption
définitive par le Parlement en décembre
[Musique]
2014 après l'échec de la gauche aux
municipales et aux Européennes du
printemps 2014 François Hollande a
besoin d'une réforme emblématique pour
relancer son quinena il joue alors son
vatou avec la réforme territoriale
objectif
simplifier le millefeuille administratif
une réforme nécessaire et plutôt bien
perçue par les Français le 3 juin il
publie une tribune dans la presse
régionale avec une nouvelle carte de 14
grandes régions principale conditions on
ne détache pas un département de sa
région
d'origine réaction immédiate on l'accuse
de l'avoir dessiné en une après-midi sur
un coin de table au gré des caprices de
certains barons socialist
Hervé Lebras et démographe auditionné
par le Sénat il regrette surtout que
l'Élysée n'it consulté aucun expert ça
s'est tramé dans un très grand secret ou
du moins ça s'est tramé au sein d'un
univers politique très étroit donc je
peux pas dire moi je n'en ai eu que des
échos vraiment parcellair mais je peux
vous donner un exemple d'écho le lundi à
midi la région des Pays de la Loire
était regroupé avec la région Centre on
faisait une grande Loire si vous voulez
d'orlé à saint-nazer et à 7h du soir la
région des Pays de la Loire était mise
avec le Poitou et on m'a assuré que
c'était sûr c'était acté et on me
demandait mon avis qui a d'ailleurs été
négatif et puis à 8 j'ai eu une un coup
de téléphone de des gens de des Pays de
la Loire avec qui je suis en relation
depuis longtemps ils m'ont dit non non
on maintenant on vient d'apprendre qu'on
restait seul qu'on restait la région des
Pays de la Loire c'est donc une
ça s fait vraiment dans une
précipitation un découpage arbitraire
mais vous allez le voir dès le départ en
1954 la création des régions a déjà un
caractère
arbitraireci vous avez Nant vous avez la
maenne vous avez la Loire leur père
c'est cet homme sergeanttoine à l'époque
jeune etarc à la Cour des comptes le
gouvernement le charge de dessiner ce
nouvel échelon administratif il s'appuie
notamment sur les découpages de l'armée
ou des eos et Forêts un travail qui lui
prendra près d'un an je me suis rendu
compte que c'était très difficile de
travailler parce que chaque
administration n'avait pas la même euh
le même découpage de la France
certains avait découpé la France en en H
grandes régions d'autres en 25 comme les
conservation des eos et forêts et si
certains mariages vont de soi d'autres
relèvent de critères plus étonnants
comme le trafic téléphonique si la laser
téléphone plus à Montpellier et moins à
Marseille je l' rattacher à à
Montpellier finalement 22 régions
sortent des cartons leurs compétences
sont alors purement
administratives pour qu'elles ai du
pouvoir il faudra attendre les lois de
fer de 1982 et des élections au suffrage
universel direct en
1986 depuis la réforme du territoire est
un serpent de mer beaucoup de dirigeants
politiques s'y sont frottés du général
de Gaulle vive la République à Nicolas
sarzi il s'agit d'une simplification et
d'une amélioration
considérable mais ce n'est pas une
solution
simpliste c'est une solution qui fait F
des querelles sans fin et sans issue
entre les prodépartements et les
prégions ce n'est ni la mort des régions
ni celle des départements c'est
l'émergence d'un pôle Région Département
doté d'un élu
vraiment plus je travaille puis je me
demande pourquoi il y a pas foncé
avant c'est désormais autour de François
Hollande de mettre cette réforme sur la
table le président de la République
brandit deux arguments créer des régions
de taille européenne et faire des
économies des arguments pas
convainquants pour
certains direction Auvergne et ronalpe
de région motivé par leur futur mariage
pour les synergies oui mais pas pour les
économies une réforme de cette nature là
qui se met en place il y a pas
d'gisement énorme d'économie il faut
arrêter de propager cette idée je ne
vois pas comment on peut faire la
moindre économie dans un délai minimum
de 5 ans d'autant plus qu'il va falloir
harmoniser le le régime inditaire des
différents personnels de Ronal et devern
le régime inditaire de ronalp est
beaucoup plus favorable que celui de
l'oververne on n'imagine pas qu'on
aligne vers le
bas faut pas voir l'Union des régions
comme la chasse au
[Musique]
fonctionnair pas question de faire la
chasse aux fonctionnaires leurs emplois
sont préservés pas question non plus de
supprimer un des hôtels de Région celui
de Ronald restera le siège de la
nouvelle entité quant au conseil
régional flamban neu de ClermontFerrand
à 80 millions d'euros inauguré en juin
2014 il gardera des fonctions
administratives et abritera les
direction pour l'agriculture et le
numérique bref pour les économies il
faudra donc
attendre d'ailleurs le gouvernement n'a
avancé qu'un seul chiffre officiel
c'était en juin 2014 à travers la voie
d'André Vallini secrétaire d'État chargé
de la réforme territoriale on peut
arriver à une dizaine de milliards
d'euros d'économie parce que 10
milliards d'euros c'est à peu près 5 %
de la masse
globale des collectivités locales la
mass globale des budgets des
collectivités locales c'est 250
milliards depuis le gouvernement a fait
machine arrière et les rares études
d'impact existante montre qu'il n'y aura
guerre d'économie à la clé comme cette
analyse de 2008 commandée par le Conseil
Régional de hauteenmandie ses
conclusions le mariage entre la haute et
la Basse Normandie coûterait jusqu'à 15
milliards d'euros dans les 10 premières
années la fusion ne serait rentable
qu'au bout de 25 ans il y a peut-être un
petit peu d'optimisme sur la
mutualisation et les économies d'échelle
qui peuvent résulter des fusions si on
prend l'exemple des lycées vous avez des
lycées dans basseenormandie des lycées
en Haute Normandie vous allez pas les
regrouper pour faire des des économies
d'échelle pas très convaincant donc cet
argument des économie autre motif
invoqué par le gouvernement créer des
régions de dimension européenne dans ce
débat important il y avait deux éléments
avoir moins de régions pour essayer
d'avoir des régions de taille d'
européenne pour mieux compter en Europe
et c'est plus que jamais à cette échelle
que nous devons raisonner nos régions
ont besoin d'une taille adapté aux
enjeux économiques et là encore un
argument balayé par les experts sur les
régions européennes ça n'a pas de sens
tous les commentateurs ont montré les
régions européennes sont très diverses
vous savez que actuellement h des 16
régions allemandes sont moins peuplées
et sont plus petites territorialement
que la plus petite des régions
françaises qui vient d'être découpé et
qui est la Bourgogne franchecté
c'està-dire il y a 8 régions allemandes
qui ont moins de 2li 800000 habitants ça
n'empêche pas ces régions d'être très
efficaces économiquement donc il faut
laisser de côté cet
argument la comparaison est un peu plus
complexe que cela entre un pays fédéral
et un état très jacobin mais peu importe
les querelles d'argument François
Hollande a décidé de frapper vite et
fort avant les élections régionales de
2015 le 18 juin 2014 Bernard casazenuve
ministre de l'Intérieur présente sa loi
en conseil des ministres c'est le
premier volet de la réforme territoriale
que contient-il principalement la carte
de François Hollande et un nouveau
calendrier pour les élections locales le
jour même il est auditionné au Sénat
chambre des collectivités est donc
saisie en premier sur ce texte comme le
veut la Constitution connu pour son
flegme le ministre va très vite se
heurter à une bronca des sénateurs de
tout bord pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de la République et peut-être
de l'État français parce que même sous
l'Ancien Régime ça se serait jamais
produit comme ça on a quand même eu des
régions des immenses régions qui ont été
définies en une après-midi par les
caprices de court et non pas par une
réflexion approfondie et si vous voulez
vraiment vous tenez absolument des
grandes régions et que vous voulez des
régions pertinentes je vois pas en quoi
le fait de de d'éventuellement séparer
un département de sa région d'origine
serait un tabou
absolu qui serait absolument inviolable
le tempon monte rapidement car les
sénateurs ont une autre préoccupation
les élections sénatoriales du 28
septembre 2014 le texte arrive au pire
moment pour eux et le gouvernement leur
impose d'aller vite ce que nous
souhaitons c'est ne pas attendre
davantage c'est prendre le risque
d'essayer c'est de faire des
propositions qui ne sont pas un se de
tout compte parce que dans cette
assemblée les propositions ne sont
jamais à solde de tout compte dès cet
instant de camp vont s'affronter au
Sénat à majorité de gauche d'un côté
socialiste vert et centriste les
défenseurs du texte de l'autre une
alliance de circonstance entre
communiste UMP et radicaux de gauche qui
va tout faire pour bloquer ce projet de
loi premier grief le calendrier on ne
souhaite
pas un débat à la hussarde hein il faut
effectivement prendre le temps de ce
débat y compris un débat public avec la
population à mon avis absolument
nécessaire et donc par exemple nous
sommes effectivement contre les
procédures d'urgence autre grief le
texte porte sur la carte mais pas sur
les compétences des régions les
sénateurs accusent le gouvernement de
mettre la charrue avant les bœfs si le
gouvernement comprend qu'il vaut mieux
attendre l'automne et le débat sur les
compétences pour faire en même temps les
compétences et la carte et ben on
travaillera ensemble au mois d'octobre
mais on refait pas la carte d'abord et
les compétences après des critiques
également sur sur le fond les sénateurs
de départements ruraux s'inquiètent de
l'enclavement de leur territoire dans
ces nouvelles régions d'autant que le
gouvernement a annoncé la suppression
des départements d'ici 2020 quand on
fait de très grandes régions et qu'on
supprime les collectivités de proximité
ça pose un problème considérable quand
par exemple le département que je
représente est rattaché à Lyon Ron Alpe
à 11h de train aller-retour ou à 9h de
route aller-retour ça pose quand même un
un vrai problème
[Musique]
dans les territoires aussi la bataille
s'organise certains ne sont pas du tout
satisfaits du mariage que leur conccté
François Hollande c'est le cas de la
Picardie avec la
champagnearden le président de la région
le socialiste claudwerk fait campagne
contre le projet on nous dit vous allez
vous marier avec champagne Arden et les
Picards disent nous sommes picards et
nos cousins germains sont les je sens
une trs très for des Picard aller se
marier avec champag le Conseil régional
lui-même a donc lancé une campagne
largement diffusé sur Internet il paraî
qu'en Picard c'est le moyenge c'est vrai
mais notre moyenge à nous il est classé
à l'Unesco et c'est ilî que la Picardie
on voudrait la faire disparaître c'est
vrai mais on nous a pas demandé la
permission et c'est
non
le 1er juillet le texte arrive enfin en
séance au Sénat mais les sénateurs
opposés au projet de loi font de
l'obstruction ils saisissent d'abord le
Conseil constitutionnel puis réclament
un référendum en 20ain est-ce que c'est
vrai on fait tout pour ralentir oh non
ça pas de toute façon c'est le
gouvernement qui veut trop accélérer
donc on le freine un petit peu mais
c'est normal ça fait partie du jeu
parlementaire en il y a toujours des
gens qui font des petites
manœuvres ceux qui sont con vont essayer
de de mettre des petits obstacles comme
ça bon moi ça m'éresse pas la procédure
parlementaire les obstructions
parlementaires mais je connais ça par
cœur jeudi 3 juillet premier jour de
séance le ministre Bernard casenu monte
au front pour défendre sa loi mais là
encore les sénateurs opposés au texte
font de l'obstruction dans les cycle la
guerre d'usure commence peut-être que le
calendrier monsieur le ministre n'est
pas absolument génial quand la moitié
des sénateurs de l'assemblée sont
renouvelables le président de la
République pourtant garant de nos
institutions nous demande de brader en
une semaine notre organisation
territoriale et 200 ans de notre
histoire républicaine partagé je vous
assure que votre réforme si vous nous la
confiez vous la sortirez alors que
vous-même vous êtes aujourd'hui en
situation très difficile pour sortir
quelque chose de positif la volonté du
gouvernement c'est que b c'est que la
réforme mais pas dans les approximations
dans les raccourcis dans les
amalgames à la fin de la séance le débat
se poursuit dans les couloirs à une
heure avancé de la
nuit pour gouvernement
[Musique]
sera
le lendemain 2è journée de séance au
cœur du débat l'article premer du texte
le découpage de la carte en Grande
Région j'espère que les sénateurs ne
vont pas s'arrêter à l'article 1er que
le débat va pouvoir aller jusqu'au bout
du texte serait utile pour le
gouvernement parce que je le répète le
gouvernement s'enrichit de tout ce qui
peut se dire au Sénat et ce serait utile
aussi pour le Sénat de montrer qu'il a
envie d'aller jusqu'au bout du débat
même si à la fin le texte est rejeté
qu'au moins on en débatte totalement le
débat aura bien lieu il faudra plus de 7
he pour aboutir à un rejet du découpage
des grandes régions les sénateurs ne
sont pas prêts pour ce vaste Big Bang
territorial la carte n'était pas mû et
ça arrange tout le monde de faire tomber
l'article 1 puisque je crois que les les
désaccords traversaient les groupes dès
qu'on rentrait dans le dans le détail de
des des fusions est-ce que la région
Centre aller avec les peds de la Loire
les PED de la Loire avec la Bretagne on
voyait que tout ça n'était pas encore
mur c'est un sentiment de déception de
regret parce que nous navons pas
accompli l'œuvre que nous aurions dû
accomplir le Sénat chambre des
collectivités aurait dû pousser ce texte
aurait dû améliorer la carte des régions
l'objectif CIT de clarifier les
compétences c'tait de faire des grandes
régions c'était de
réaménager l'administration territoriale
nous navons pas réussi à le faire j'ai
peur que le Sénat soit tiré une balle
dans le pied j'espère que les gens ne se
poseront pas la question de à quoi sert
le Sénat si n n'arrivons pas à avoir une
majorité transversale sur des sujets
comme cela le Sénat est libre il est
évident que cela gêne beaucoup tous les
gouvernements quelle que soit la
sensibilité politique de chaque
gouvernement et pourquoi il en est voulu
au Sénat parce que le Sénat a l'habitude
de travailler sur le fond et d'exprimer
sa liberté dans l'intérêt de la
[Musique]
républiquection régionale et
départemental mod le 23 juillet
l'Assemblée nationale se saisit du texte
et vote une carte de 13 régions au Nord
la Picardie est désormais mariée au
nordp de Calais et plus à la
champagneardene qui rejoint elle la
grande région est avec la Lorine et
l'Alsace enfin à l'ouest Limousin et
poitouchearante sont rattachés à
Laquitaine la région Centre reste
seul dans les futures grandes régions le
chef-lieu sera fixé par décret sur avis
des conseils régionaux pas facile de se
mettre d'accord dans certains cas comme
entre camp et Ran r ran ouais ben moi
je ran quand pour les élus auonormand
les jeux sont faits au 1er janvier 2015
ran deviendra métropole sur l'axe scène
elle a donc tout d'une capitale il nous
faut une locomotive et qui participe de
l'entraînement de de de tous les
territoires
encore une fois sans opposition avec
l'ensemble de ce qu'elle doit contribuer
à animer et nous avons là une métropole
reconnu par le législateur ni plus ni
[Musique]
moins un choix contesté en
bass-normandie pour le président du
conseil général du Calvados jeanlon d
pont la métropole rouanaise accaparera
tous les budgets au détriment de camp et
des communes alentours une grosse
crainte en particulier des banormand
c'est le risque de passer au-delà des
effets bénéfiques si vous voulez de ne
pas être forcément dans du gagnant
gagnant mais de regarder un
développement qui aurait lieu sur l'axe
scène qui partirait grosso modo de la
région parisienne et de Paris en passant
bien sûr par rouan et par Le Havre et
qui évidemment délaisserait la Basse
Normandie
entre les deux agglomérations la
bataille de Normandie est loin d'être
finie la réforme territoriale va
lourdement peser sur la campagne des
sénatorial
qui voit une large victoire de la droite
le 28 septembre
2014 prochaine étape l'indispensable
renouveau du
sénattin pour l'élection du président
dans la foué Gérard Larcher est élu
président du Sénat monsieur Gérard larch
obtenu la majorité absolu des suffrages
exprimés je le proclame président du
Sénat
un de ses premiers gestes c'est
d'inviter l'exécutif à venir clarifier
sa réforme devant les
sénateurs c'est ici qui la chambre des
territoires non pas que nous dignion à
l'Assemblée nationale sa responsabilité
mais qu' il était important que le
gouvernement sente bien quiici quel que
soit le groupe la question des
territoires est quelque chose de
fondamental ça n'est pas le se métier
entre il met du Sénat mais c'est
important changement de majorité et
changement d'état d'esprit parmi les
sénateurs qui sont maintenant décidés à
être acteur de cette réforme sous la
houlette du nouveau rapporteur l'UMP
François Noël buffet ils parviennent à
un accord on a essayé d'être constructif
je crois le plus possible pour que le
Sénat reprenne la main sur la majorité
sénatoriale nouvelle reprenne la main
sur ce texte c'était ça aussi le but
politique faut dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont nous y sommes arrivés à
cette première étape encore faut-il
maintenant emmener le texte jusqu'au
bout c'est déjà très positif quand même
par rapport au débat que nous avons eu
en première lecture où il y avait une
volonté de bloquer de ralentir de
saboter le travail législatif là il y a
vraiment une attitude très constructive
et d'ailleurs on arrive quand même à
voter un texte avec l'essentiel quand
même de ce que vou le gouvernement les
grandes régions la date des élections il
a juste sur la carte qui a encore
quelques diverg une carte avec 15
régions l'Alsace obtient de rester seul
avec un statut particulier et quitte la
grande région est avec Lorine et
champagnearden langdoc Rousillon et midi
piréné sont désormais séparés un débat
apaisé au Sénat alors que certaines
régions se préparent déjà à se marier
comme Auvergne et ronalpe leurs deux
présidents ont mis au point un comité de
pilotage président oui
j'arve ou oui j'avais lein ch tu arrivé
à quelle heure toi là euh il y a 1 heure
il y a 1 heure
ok formation professionnelle canceropôle
train direct quotidien entre Lyon et
Clermont les annonces se multiplient
pour rationaliser et mutualiser les
services avec un objectif être prêt pour
janvier 2016 après les élections
régionales de 2015 nous l'objectif c'est
que on soit prêt et donc on a une année
pour préparer et de le faire dans de
bonnes conditions et nous sommes donc
très satisfaits du climat qui nous
permet de faire ce travail de
coconstruction et et pour prolonger ce
que dit à l'instant Jean-Jacques dans
l'opinion publique aujourd'hui notre
sentiment c'est que la population en a
assez des querelles politiciennes qui
alimentent les débats des radios tous
les matins je pense que par rapport aux
autres qui doivent fusionner qui parfois
sont en conflit sur tel ou tel sujet
nous avons la volonté de
construire reste une inquiétude les
territoires ruraux redoutent d'être
oublié dans ses grand région leur maire
manifeste devant le Sénat marchez avec
nous marchez avec nous il demandent aux
parlementaires de mettre la pression sur
le gouvernement nous savons que l'esprit
de la réforme aujourd'hui vise à
supprimer les échants de proximité pour
aller conforter des échelons urbains
supérieurs et nous pensons que on peut
raisonner différemment que la question
c'est d'abord une question
d'aménlagement du territoire et ensuite
une question d'organisation territoriale
dans pour la deuxè lecture manuel Vals
invité par Gérard Larcher explique sa
réforme devant le nouveau Sénat de
droite cette fois mais les relations
entre manuel Vals et la Haute Assemblée
sont loin d'être
simples quel
point très bien bon c'est un débat vous
allez voir on va parler de allez-y
allezzour c'est un conseil municipal de
conseil municipal de jeune TR très bien
on commence comme ça et on termine
[Musique]
sénateur un grand oral qui va durer plus
de 3 He à la sortie le président du
Sénat se
félicite nous voyons que nous pouvons
aller dans un d'abord dans un vrai débat
on a donc rebasé les principes de la
réforme territoriale j'ai entendu un
Premier ministre qui disait ce soir
qu'il avait envie d'écouter d'entendre
le Sénat et puis on verra nos
convergences et nos divergences
rapidement d'autres dénoncent un jeu de
dupe le Premier ministre donne des gages
sur des réformes à venir mais reste
ferme sur le redécoupage nous avons
besoin de clarté et à mon sens la carte
votée à l'Assemblée nationale a ce
mérite j'ai reconnu le grand écart entre
les discours et les actes chers au Parti
socialiste des déclarations
effectivement très positive je vais
écouter le Sénat c'est important les
territoires et puis voilà ma carte
socialiste adopté à l'Assemblée
nationale je vais l'imposer c'est bien
la preuve que il n'y a pas de ligne
directrice il procède au coup par coup
en au gré des circonstances des humeurs
des uns et des autres et c'est tout
l'examen du texte se poursuit ensuite
avec les deux ministres en charge de la
réforme encore 48 heur de débat avec les
mêmes arguments souvent rebattus et des
passes d'armes parfois violentes ayez un
petit peu quand même le temps de la
réflexion pour vous dire
que les conséquences en terme de
regroupement que vous ne voulez pas chez
vous elles seront ailleurs et bien
défendez votre région défendez votre
projet ce que je vous dis madame c'est
qu'on a le droit de ne pas être d'accord
et d'arriver aux mêmes objectifs de
grandes régions élargies madame
simplement ne méprisant pas les
territoires et en faisant en sorte de ne
pas les planter durablement en mettant
la chue avant les B non mais la carte
idéale elle existe si à condition de la
faire autrement c'estd les compétences
avant mais non même avec les compétences
avant tu n'arrives jamais à un accord
total jamais si avec moi-même je suis
toujours d'AC bah le président de la
République il est d'accord
avec j'espère qui est pour cet
amendement finalement le Sénat adopte le
même texte et surtout la même carte des
régions qu'en commission un travail
immédiatement effacé par les députés en
deuxè lecture l'Assemblée revient donc à
sa carte de 13 régions langd Roussillon
et midi pirené sont de nouveau marié
l'Alsace réintègre la grande région est
aux grand dam des élus locaux c'est le
principal point de friction dans ce
découpage les Alsaciens restent
mobilisés jusqu'au bout contre ce
mariage pourtant les jeux sont faits
nous voulons pouvoir décider librement
de notre destin et nous voulons pas que
ça se décide à Paris ou je ne sais où
des gens qui ne connaissent pas notre
situation qui nous connaissent pas et
même qui nous méprisent qui nous
ignorent en général aucune carte ne fera
jamais l'unanimité le consensus total il
n'existe pas il est très rare en
politique le consensus tot mais sur une
carte régionale il est tout simplement
impossible c'est donc la carte voulue
par l'Assemblée et le gouvernement qui
est adopté est-ce pour autant un échec
pour le Sénat qui n'aura pas réussi à
s'imposer dans le débat c'est la
Constitution française l'Assemblée
nationale a le dernier mot sur tous les
textes et pas aujourd'hui depuis des
dizaines d'années donc voilà c'est comme
ça mais le bicamer ça n'est
jamais un parallélisme entre les deux
assemblées souvenez-vous le Sénat le
premier mot et depuis la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2008 c'est le texte
de la commission qui est examiné et nous
avons le premier mot c'est peut-être
aussi important que d'avoir le dernier
mot le Sénat aura tout de même enrichi
le texte avec le droit d'option pour les
départements qui souhaitent changer de
région et une meilleure représentation
des départements ruraux François
Hollande a réussi son pari le nombre de
régions est divisé par presque 2 il
passe de 22 à 13 dans la foulée le
président de la République s'attaque à
la refondte des compétences des
différents échelons prévu pour 2015 un
vaste chantier en vue de simplifier
enfin le maillage
[Musique]
territorial